coffee Zillow you have previously only
made exceptional and well-researched
videos and now that you did one about me
that track record means nothing coffee
you are incredibly talented and
remarkably handsome but you're basically
a cop but as opposed to telling you I'm
going to show you the discrepancies I
caught in your video about my scan one
you did not disclose that I hired a
bunch of criminals for this project are
you trying to protect them or are you
trying to protect me from something that
arguably makes me look worse you like me
is that why do you have a tiny little
crush on me because if if you did that
wouldn't even be that big of a problem
I'd actually be kind of happy about that
two you contacted my manager instead of
me directly for comment do you think
he's going to get that message through
to me
job I mean unless it is in which case of
a well I don't really know what he does
then when you did get through to me it
was on Christmas Eve do you want to ruin
this little guy's Christmas helps drink
an eggnog with the homies roasting
chestnuts by the fire what is wrong with
you now let me reiterate I did hire a
bunch of criminals who scammed people
but the real victim of all of this is my
reputation which I have spent so much
time and money trying to rehabilitate
ever since that incident the thing we
don't talk we don't have to we we don't
have to talk about coffee Zilla look
you're a cutie you're a little cutie pie
I'm not going to deny that and I love
you like a dear friend
but you are a frog and I hate you and I
will see you in court